can you break down how ESG was sold
meaning why did some people think this
was a good idea and why do you think
it's not a good idea so the origin story
of the modern version of it starts with
the 2008 financial crisis okay what
happened in the 08 crisis actually
there's two things that happened in 08
that were really interesting in the back
of the 2008 financial crisis one was a
mistake made by the Republican party
which was to bail out the big banks that
was I remind you Hank Paulson an alumnus
of Goldman Sachs who used taxpayer money
to bail out Goldman Sachs under
President Bush that happened and what
happened in response to that was you had
a left-wing backlash by the way I think
that was crony capitalism all the way
down I was a Critic of it at the time I
remained a Critic of it today there was
a left-wing backlash that said you know
what if that's the way you're going to
behave then we Occupy Wall Street want
to take money from all of those wealthy
corporate fat cats and bankers and
redistribute it to poor people to help
poor people agree or not that is what
they had to say it was a coherent it was
a coherent response if you ask me
now
right around that time a second Trend
was happening in sort of the political
socio-political life of our country
Barack Obama was elected as president of
the United States there was the birth of
a new strand of the left so not the
Occupy Wall Street left but a new strand
of the left said you know what it's not
quite economic Injustice or poverty that
we care about not just that
there's there's the real problem that
has to do with racism
and misogyny and bigotry and climate
change that's a become a big one the
biggest yes the biggest biggest one of
all right I think wokism is one religion
climatism is a religion the dwarfs woke
is in by comparison but anyway they said
this is this is the sort of the new
theory of the case and what happened
was that this was the opportunity of a
generation for big business in this
country for Wall Street in particular
because if you're Wall Street Occupy
Wall Street
it's a pretty tough pill to swallow
bitter medicine okay right
the new work stuff is pretty easy
you applaud diversity and inclusion put
some token minorities on your executive
ranks or your boards or whatever Muse
about the racially disparate impact of
climate change after you fly on that
private jet in Davos
this could work if you can get it
but they didn't do it for free and
that's what this whole ESG stakeholder
capitalism thing is about they made a
new demand to the new left that says you
look the other way when it comes to
leaving our corporate power intact
and so it's the sort of arranged
marriage actually my parents are from
India they had an arranged marriage that
was the good kind you're like I know it
all too familiar I get it I mean there's
I didn't mean to like use that term in a
negative sense they had a good kind of
arrangement but this this is
this is not an arranged marriage of Love
okay this is this is mutual prostitution
each side gets something out of the
trade and the net result of that the
bastard child was the birth of this ESG
movement the ESG industrial complex this
apologist model of capitalism that says
you have to advance these Progressive
agendas as a way of atoning for your sin
in the 2008 financial crisis but even
more as a way of if you can't beat them
buy them and that's effectively the
mutual codependent relationship between
a progressive movement that used to hate
big business but instead got in bed with
them and together you know big Banks
woke Millennials get in bed they both
capitalism and they use that to
sacrifice Occupy Wall Street which they
put up for adoption so anyway that's a
little bit of the history of this game
why am I upset about it
yes Milton Friedman correctly said that
this would make businesses less
efficient and they would be less good at
making widgets and then that shrinks the
size of the economic pie and we're all
worse off and we all know that old
school conservative classical
conservative neo-libertarian argument
I actually agree with most of it by the
way
but that's not what gets me going on
this issue okay my concern
was not that politics would infect
capitalism not just that but that
capitalism would infect democracy
because what this worldview says
is that the way you settle questions
like climate change or systemic racism
or whatever it might be
is not the way we do it here in America
which is through free speech and open
debate in the Public Square where every
person's voice and vote counts equally
that was the bargain we struck in 1776
for better Awards that's how we do it
over here
but that we got to go back to doing it
the way they used to do in the old world
back in Old World aristocratic Europe
where a small group of business Elites
and labor Elites and church Elites got
together behind closed doors and decided
what was right for the rest of society
at Large
and that's why I sort of try to educate
people this is not a Republican versus
Democrat 2022 or 2023 issue
this is a 1776 issue and it's a question
of how you settle disagreements in a
society is it as Citizens with an equal
Voice through a democratic process or is
it through some type of aristocratic
monarchical structure where some guy
named Larry Fink Singh on Park Avenue
gets to use your money to tell you what
kind of society he will create even if
it's one you didn't vote for so I was
watching this documentary it's like a
19-minute documentary Bloomberg did I
don't know if you've seen it or not
where they're telling a love story it's
it's a different story than the one
you're talking about and they're telling
a story about Robert Schwartz if you can
pull up Robert Schwartz and Robert zevin
just type in Robert Schwartz and Robert
zevin to just do the name don't even
worry about the documentary just to
Robert Schwartz right there and let's
see what comes up uh uh underneath
Robert Schwartz just write ESG right
next to Robert Schwartz right ESG let's
see what pulls up
so there's a what was the second name
seven oh it's that one right there he
died in 2006. that Wikipedia right there
go down that one right there yeah zoom
in
zoom in so this is uh he was a U.S porn
Economist and a stockbroker he was an
early advocate of socially responsible
investing he was also actively
campaigned for civil rights against the
Vietnam War the use of nuclear weapons
he actively participated in
organizations such as American veterans
committee Americans for Democratic
action sane in 1989 he founded
Economist against the arms race now
called Economist for peace and security
so the story says how these guys
originally
felt capitalism was a problem and the
right way of doing it is to force
businesses to be socially uh uh
conscious of what they're doing to keep
give money back obviously they're very
left on what they're doing so the story
was there you know this is uh uh 30
trillion dollars of money being invested
back into the into people 35 trillion
dollars being invested back into the
world that we live in and it again it
sounds very convincing okay where a lot
of people are falling for it I remember
when we were selling our insurance
company
uh and we were going with uh Folks at
Houlihan located we're sitting with
Buyers okay you know the process you've
gone through this before
and so we're sitting down I said oh so
tell us your uh I'm like so what does
your company look like well our hardest
biggest challenge we have is we have a
thousand investment bankers that work
with us but uh uh only five percent are
African Americans six percent are
Hispanics and we're really having a hard
time with that I said oh really I said
you know our di score is this and this
this that and they're asking about the
DI score right I said okay yeah you know
we're 54 Hispanic you know we're 51
percent women and you know the average
agent is 34 years do you see like their
facing lighting their faces is like oh
this could uh this is so you guys have a
very so and then they started talking
you know uh uh how this could impact
their di score the look on their face
they were more interested on what this
is going to do their Dei score in the
marketplace that's right then the
investment of course which was
completely Supply yeah it's a different
kind of scoring system right it's like
ESG scores go into your credit rating
that affects whether or not you can
borrow more expenses right not right so
there's a couple things going on here
okay so first there was this socially
responsible investing movement and you
described it perfectly that exactly was
the goal use Capital as a lever to drive
positive social change or what someone
would determine is positive social
change
the question they skip is who gets to
decide what is positive or not if these
are contested public policy issues right
that means they're contested because
people human beings citizens disagree
about it and we have to decide what's
the way we work out our differences is
it through Force
including economic force or is it
through a process of debate in a
democratic body politic I thought we
lived in the latter Old World Europe and
actually In fairness by the way I just
want to say anything to be fair about
this for most of human history that's
not how it's been settled okay this is
relatively new idea I mean existed in
ancient Greece in some sense but in
modern history this relatively new idea
you actually have most questions that
were settled through Force either
physical force or through other Elite
interventions so this American thing we
got going on here this is a departure
from history but that's the experiment
that I signed up for or at least my
parents signed up for I signed up for
about being born here my parents parents
signed up for by coming here that was
the American way and so to me that's the
first question is who gets to decide
what the right answers are but the
second thing is what's going on with ESG
right now
is different that is to say it goes
beyond what was going on with the
sustainable or the socially responsible
investing SRI movement
so there what they were doing was saying
and by the way when I was a student at
Harvard the endowment at Harvard you
know some people 60 billion dollars some
people joke around that Harvard is a
giant hedge fund with a college attached
to it correct right so what they would
do is they would kind of use their
Capital to divest from Sudan or divest
from conflict areas and then take a lot
of credit for it and issue nice press
releases that was what socially
responsible investment was about mostly
is divestment okay take the bad sectors
pick whatever you think is bad tobacco
coal oil Sudan cigarette you know
whatever gaming Firearms is a big one
divest and then hopefully if you divest
that will then cause those companies to
change their behavior what ended up
really happening was that we have deep
liquid Global Capital markets so if
those stock prices go down for example
or asset prices go down the inherent
worth of the activity the commercial
value of it hasn't changed that just
created an opportunity for somebody else
to buy it up instead and so what ended
up happening is the guys who want to
issue the press releases end up giving
up return the guys who don't care about
the press releases would rather stay
Anonymous end up being the other side of
that trade they just get to buy it at a
lower price and that's why UT's
University of Texas's system has
outperformed Harvard's endowment because
Harvard got out of fossil fuels while
the University of Texas didn't over the
course of 2022. so what the ESG movement
does is one step goes one step further
than that and this is where I'm focused
okay
BlackRock State Street Vanguard these
are three of the largest financial
institutions they manage about 20
trillion dollars almost as much Capital
as the US GDP in the hands of three
institutions but what they're mostly
doing isn't just the socially
responsible investing thing through
their ESG funds it's common
misconception that's a tiny tiny tiny
part of what they do like less than two
percent or something okay
most of what they do is they're actually
just providing index funds to the
general population people who think they
own the S P 500 who think they own apple
and Nike and and you know whatever you
name the company Exxon Chevron Etc
but the key is they're not divesting
through those funds they're invested in
the whole Market in fact who are the top
shareholders of Disney and Paramount
Pictures of apple and Microsoft of Exxon
and Chevron it's the same companies
actually the same large shareholders are
the institutions that hold these firms
they're using the money of everyday
citizens to do it but they're changing
the behaviors of those underlying
companies by voting their shares
and by advocating for policies in the
boardroom
that change the companies themselves so
here it's not divesting from Apple
because they didn't do a racial Equity
audit it's being invested in apple and
making apple do a racial Equity audit at
their company last year
that Apple itself did not want to do
Apple's board said absolutely not
BlackRock and State Street said um
actually you're going to do it because
we're your shareholders and we're the
ones that demand it now the funny part
is it's not like Larry Fink or BlackRock
is the actual shareholder it's probably
most listeners to this program whose
money is invested in their funds but
don't know that their money is being
voted in this direction so that's the
key with the the main where the main
action is on the ESG debate isn't the
divestment game yeah it's the voting
game so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]